Since 2.5 million years ago, humanity has begun to eat meat.
Before that, our ancestors followed a plant system made up of berries and flowers
Later humankind began to eat more seeds and nuts, which gave them more fat
And less fiber, then our bodies began to prepare to eat meat.
But what happens if we eat meat only?
Without eating high-fiber foods such as lentils, beans and broccoli
You will get constipated and feel uncomfortable.
Not to mention that the easiest way to make energy in the body
Are converting carbohydrates into glucose.
In the absence of carbohydrates, your body will burn fat and crush the necessary proteins.
The process of making glucose from the protein is called the development of glucose,
It occurs in the liver and leads to the formation of nitrogen residues which in turn turn into urea.
But a lot of urea leads to protein poisoning,
Causing nausea and diarrhea and increasing the risk of death.
Even if you eat meat as dry as rabbit meat, which contains very little fat
Where you can eat a lot and lots of it and eventually become lean.
Another killer is vitamin C deficiency.
Humans are organisms that can not form vitamin C themselves.
Without vitamin C in fruits and vegetables,
Your body will not be able to make effective collagen
It is a structural protein that can be found in tendons, ligaments and skin.
This will increase your risk of scurvy, which causes slow wound healing
Gingival necrosis and personality changes.
If you are not treated, you will die from infection or bleeding.
But eating raw meat can prevent it from happening
Cooked meat reduces vitamin C,
But the whale and fat of the raw and thick whales is rich in rubber collagen, with one serving (100 grams) containing 36 milligrams of vitamin C.
More than 10 milligrams of grams needed to prevent scurvy.
This leads us to an interesting situation,
Caused by low temperatures and difficult environment
The traditional Esquimos diet depends on what fish and fish they eat
And few plant foods, dairy products and carbohydrates if any.
However, the heart rate is half that of Americans and Canadians.
How can you be healthy by following a diet rich in fat and not containing fruit or vegetables?
You can eat snacks of meat as liver in order to get your recommended share of vitamin A.
Which is essential for eyes, bones and vitamin D (essential for your bones as well)
Fish oil rich in omega-3 fatty acids that will benefit the heart and blood vessels.
Eskimo bodies have adapted to glucose control, and have helped them have a heavier liver than usual
And increased urine volumes to get rid of extra urea.
A recent genetic study of Eskimo genes in Greenland,
They found a variety of alternatives that cause protective effects on cholesterol and triglycerides.
So they can rely on meat only,
But it is important to know that communities in the North of the world have relied on animal food as a result of the conditions and urgency.
The goal of a high-fat diet is to maintain their weight throughout the fishing period, or when food is not available
Not for weight loss, such as low-carb modern diets.
Unless you plan to eat whale fat and organic meat
Your genes were in good shape. Maintain a balanced diet that includes all major food groups.
Translation: team translate @Autrjim